un mètre soixante dix et originaire de
la commune de poroani ramatou rajab eau
et la miss mayotte depuis le mois d'août
dernier sur le chemin de l'élection de
miss france elle a fait escale à la
réunion
bonjour on est allé se passe raide mais
qui se trouve au bas de la rivière
aujourd'hui on est là pour pour les
femmes de m c'est ce qu'on a les femmes
au rêve
on a aussi une association semble au
bout
lui vaut toutefois pas comme d'habitude
un journée de soutien pour accompagner
cette candidate qui a été la cible de
propos racistes et de moqueries sur les
réseaux sociaux la communauté mahoraise
tenez à lui apporter son soutien
je vous mentirais si je dis que personne
n'a besoin de personne
parce que c'est faux tout le monde a
besoin de tout le monde parce qu'on peut
pas on peut pas être soi même et être
totalement soi-même toujours on a besoin
de l'autre l'un de l'autre
ce soit ici à la réunion ou à mayotte
surtout que vaut elle est l'aînée à la
réunion sa maman habite ici pour nous il
était impératif de l'année bond en lieu
de sa naissance
bagis une ambassadrice des usa est
incertain surtout parce que j'étais à la
réunion
ces grandeurs en tant que membre est ici
on faisait du débat ensemble avec
l'association aujourd'hui défendent et
je suis parti et sont revenus avec une
jambe en bourse et même s'il ya miss
réunion malice mais tu es là aussi est
mieux que la meilleure gagne
m
personnellement rêve et pantling lui
c'est souvent pour les fêtes les
mariages
c'est une tradition chez nous
mais c'est une danse que pour les femmes
réservé aux femmes que chez les hommes
quitteront un bailleur et fromagers
une place près médecine jamais parce que
à mayotte c'est les femmes qui gèrent à
lamaison mais aussi
mais aussi de hors jeu
maintenant elle encore elles prennent de
plus en plus d'ampleur dans la société
maurel
un moment festif pour accompagner la
cohésion sociale entre les communautés
les femmes étaient habillées par des
groupes de couleur c'est des
associations comme vous et des cham 1,5
une sacoche choisis sont issus et parent
pour reconnaître les différentes
associations pour montrer que voilà même
si on est une association on a pu se
réunir et de la part vous pour une
couleur comment connais la réunion est
un peu plus multiculturel donc oui on
doit se comprendre à s'écouter danse
jouer ensemble s'amuser ensemble et
partager les différentes cultures
c'est une communauté qui s'est assez
bien intégré il ya intégré et le
département fait tout pour que s'attaque
cette intégration se fasse dans les
meilleures conditions de ce vivre
ensemble j'espère que ça va continuer
dans les meilleures conditions
donc aujourd'hui il est question
d'encourager notre miss mayotte pour
l'élection de miss france donc je lui
souhaite bon courage et bon vent pour la
suite
espérons que ça sera une belle aventure
et que l on reviendra l'année pas nuit
avec plein d'expérience ramatou rajab au
est maintenant sur paris la 86e édition
de miss france se déroulera le 19
décembre prochain au zénith de lille